when Mitch Daniels served as governor of
Indiana from 2005 to 2013 he would apply
what he called the yellow pages test
that is if some agency or function is
listed in the yellow pages the
government shouldn't be doing it during
his eight years in office Daniels led
one of the most successful cost-cutting
and privatization campaigns in modern
political history he contracted out
welfare services started a school
voucher program slashed the size of the
state workforce and ended collective
bargaining for public employees in one
of his most controversial moves
Daniel's leased a 157 Mile toll road to
a group of private investors a deal that
brought nearly four billion dollars to
the state by the end of his second term
Indiana's workforce was 18% smaller its
credit rating was upgraded to triple-a
for the first time in history and even
the state's long hated Bureau of Motor
Vehicles had become known for its
excellent customer service this record
in the face of recession led some
Republicans to Pine openly for a mitch
Daniels run at the 2012 GOP nomination
for president but the governor declined
now the president of Purdue University
Daniels has kept his thrifty habits in
tact privatizing some services and
applying a tuition freeze to keep higher
education affordable for middle class
families
this May mitch Daniels became the first
recipient of the recent Foundation's
annual Savas award for public-private
partnerships I sat down with him for an
interview before the ceremony you
inherited deficits of two hundred
million dollars eight hundred yeah why
public sector unions why is that a focus
straight out of the bat what's the
importance of fact it wasn't primarily
about money
we had to address that the old-fashioned
way and and reconcile spending with
revenue and so forth
no it was much more about column work
rules but something like 160 pages of
do's and don'ts in these agreements that
the state had signed and I used to say
you know you couldn't pick up a coffee
cup from one desk and move it to the
next without a 30-day 60-day
consultation with somebody you certainly
couldn't as we were determined to do
combined departments break off
departments for more direct supervision
you certainly couldn't outsource
anything under those conditions if we'd
have been paralyzed really to from doing
those things that would make government
work so it was much more about making a
totally dysfunctional government operate
effectively within the zone the more
limited zone that we thought it not
operate at all
now Wisconsin obviously became the site
of three years worth of yeah
worthless scuttlebutt over this even
though there was hurricane mention I'm
sure it felt crazy in the eye of the
storm it didn't feel like the same kind
of thing why didn't that happen in
Indiana well well we were able to strike
quickly and did I get here now here's a
confession I I don't often procrastinate
or over cogitate and so forth but on
that decision I really spent a long time
I was trying to talk myself into either
waiting till after the legislative
session or maybe splitting the baby
somehow maybe these important
departments and not these the the key
distinction was we didn't need
legislation as in almost everywhere
other venue including the federal
government when JFK did it collective
bargaining was in which FDR and you know
Fiorello LaGuardia and lots of friends
of unions always said had no place in
the public sector had gotten there
always almost always through executive
orders later codified in statute Indiana
the advocates of collective bargaining
never got got it into statute so I had
the ability which Walker did not to take
it out by executive order I tried to
persuade myself though that maybe we
shouldn't do it right away because I
could imagine a scene like we saw in
Wisconsin and I thought man the whole
rest of this agenda we've got this huge
agenda of things that we think are
really important to do and I could
imagine it all being brought to a whole
if we had a an eruption like they did
instead on day I just finally decided no
we cannot fix this place under these
conditions we're just going to have to
take this action and hope for the best
so I went and told the union leaders
myself my first day in office thought
they deserve to hear it from me
went back signed the order pulled up the
covers and helped I breath and nothing
happened except that over the first
about 11 months 90 plus percent of the
state employees stopped paying the dues
once it was their choice they gave
themselves a pay raise I think the
swiftness maybe maybe they just didn't
think we'd do it but we did it and then
their members began to speak at least
tacitly and it was never an issue and
you this led to be able to reduce the
state workforce by some 18 percent tell
us about the kind of knock-on practical
benefits that you've received from doing
yeah some of it had to do simply with
being able to organize the government
for better effect good example we had
the worst child protection system in the
country HHS was finding us and probably
deservedly so the ratios of people who
are supposed to be watching over these
endangered children were way out of
whack no training and all that so we had
pledged to do something direct about
that pulled it out of this massive
social services bureaucracy and created
a a unit entirely of its own reporting
directly to the governor and five years
later we were winning national awards
but that's that sort of of restructuring
or combining units that in and
extracting the synergies that were
possible there you know in most of life
I always say pretty much a libertarian
but when it comes to IT I believe in
dictatorship you can't let everybody
have their own computers and their own
little customized software so nothing
talks to each other right and so a
establishing one unitary and unified IT
system across all of government I still
bump into people said how did you get
that done because it's a it's a problem
that afflicts a lot of large
organizations private and public and so
things like that and we were able to go
straight for them you know we went right
away to a new benefits plan which is
HSAs Indiana rather quickly had almost
all state employees on a what we now
call a consumerist or a high deductible
plan the penetration of such plans in
public sector America last I looked was
about one Wow one or two percent and we
must have been half of that because we
were 90 plus couldn't have done that
save buckets of money employees wound up
with millions of dollars accumulating in
their accounts which are their says you
know how that works
and likewise Indiana as far as I know is
still the only state that has a we
reformed the civil service rules such
that employees are paid for performance
not in lockstep grids the best
performers got the biggest pay raises by
far in state history those that the
other end got a warning and often and a
second chance but that's that's all they
got
so those are the sorts of things it was
now that translated into dollars sure it
did but I just am stressing here that
our principal objective was to
demonstrate that government actually
could deliver every state hates its
license branches right
I guarantee Indiana probably had a
candidate for the worst I used to say
that people went to in Indiana Bureau
Motor Vehicles office with a box lunch
and a copy of war and peace and hope not
to finish both of them you know before
somebody noticed they were there so by
about three or four years in there
winning national awards I'd get a report
once a month
the average visit time door-to-door was
down to nine minutes and something the
average customer satisfaction was 97
percent at a DMV that's right that's
crazy talk
well I live in Brooklyn I think the
average time is five and a half days
something business school case has been
cases have been written about it's a
very interesting story all by itself a
lot of that was accomplished by the way
by creating all sorts of ways that you
didn't have to go to the branch in the
first place if you didn't want to write
online in the mail on the phone etc but
and you know I was really fixed on those
things that touched lots of people so
everybody has to deal with the bureau
Motor Vehicles
everybody has to deal with the
Department of Revenue we really worked
hard on those so people could see
practical benefits and yes because and I
saw that also as an important investment
of capital and that metaphorical sense
because you know first of all I'm a
limited government person of the first
order but I don't think that
unadulterated cynicism about government
is healthy for our democracy and so
number one I wanted people to develop a
sense of confidence that the folks were
running the people's business really
were committed to try to do it well and
the second thing was that want to build
momentum for the next reform and
literally I think a lot of people
concluded well they can fix the dam BMV
maybe that new idea they've got is worth
a look to talk a little bit about
privatization both in terms of what you
did there but also where did you get
acquainted where than enamored with the
idea to begin with yeah in in the early
90s a lot of people were enamored with
it I was convinced it was such an
obvious and smart thing to do so fellow
named Osborn was reputed to be Bill
Clinton's favorite thinker at the time
and he writes a book reinventing
government or something was the title
and there's all about this
using the private sector where
appropriate to deliver services more
effectively and efficiently sure a very
a good friend and a really good public
official named Steve Goldsmith got
elected mayor in my hometown and when he
was running I said to him you know
you're gonna want a signature a thing
your predecessors have had some big ones
and you should want one I said this
business of privatizing services for the
benefit of service recipients and
taxpayers is a good one
why don't you have it I said why don't
you have a citizen's Commission to go
look through state government see where
the opportunities are in art so he got
it you know so big mistake because he
makes me the chairman of the Commission
we got some great people some good
business people and they they would
divided local government into functional
areas people went in and came out with I
don't know a host of ideas so that's
where I got and most of them got acted
on so that's where I I guess got the
notion but I got a lot of it from
reading Reason magazine not to kiss up
here but it's true and poole sure all
this at a time when I had no intention
no premonition that I'd ever hold
elected office myself that's interesting
no I just never expected that to be the
case but it came when it came along I
had the benefit of the reading I had
done and and the experi experience now
the most notorious or infamous or
something
least controversial privatization was I
guess one of your first which is a toll
road why was that controversial of all
things in the world because it's an
interesting thing because it is the it
is that beyond any question it was a
slam dunk Grand Slams spectacular
success I mean we were very
self-critical our administration most
things you know give yourself a B or B
plus but not this one we had valued the
road in public hands around a billion
three billion
and you had to make some rosy
assumptions to get it up to that and I
had told myself if the bids come in if
their bids aren't well over two we
probably won't it won't be worth going
for it but if they get up there closer
to what we're aiming at we will
so the bid comes in 3.9 billion dollars
unbelievable and when I announced it on
a Monday morning into a jam packed room
all that you know there were gasps and
cheers and clapping and everybody in
that room at that moment believed this
thing would fly because holy cow well
you say what happened xenophobia happen
the the notion that well first of all
there was just some vague sense which
our partisan opposition pounced on that
maybe we were giving something up you
know people didn't understand
necessarily a transaction at the
beginning then maybe and then the fact
that the financing was organized by a
foreign entity Australian bank you know
how those Australians conveyed come on
yeah yeah a friend of mine said he went
in a barber shop when the thing was
really white-hot and people and they're
arguing about it and he said he finally
said you know you're right it's worse
than it's even worse than I thought I'd
just been out there they've changed all
the signs to Australia so it became what
could have been and should have been a
bipartisan celebration became a very
partisan thing but you know we got it
through and the results speak for
themselves
we're we're in the tenth of ten
consecutive years of record
infrastructure investment Indiana and
there are more than 200 projects that
wouldn't have happened that did
including some big ones that people had
waited for literally for decades and
and a big fraction of all the bridges in
the state were rebuilt so there's still
more to do always will be but it was a
there was a tremendous piece of luck for
the state here's the thing that haunts
me on that day when I made that
announcement I pointed out that as of
the closing that we were headed for this
would be the largest such transaction in
American history by a factor of two it
was about twice as big as the Chicago
Skyway which was the biggest one at the
time I said but that won't last that
won't last a year because this is such a
obvious partial answer to the national
problem we have of infrastructure that
other places it's being done all over
the world already anyway it's just a
little late getting here to America look
for this to happen a lot of other places
astonishingly to me we sit here a decade
later and it's still the still the
record and that's a darn shame your
record as governor of Indiana at a time
when we went to the financial crisis
when we started seeing trillion-dollar
annual federal deficits got you very
much in the conversation in the 2012
presidential race like he's the wonk
there's government covering lunk that we
need and somewhere in 2010 I guess you
made a statement that had libertarians
just high fiving and conservatives not
quite so high fiving about how
Republicans or conservatives need to
start thinking in terms of a truce on
social issues looking back on that and
transposing it today do you still feel
that and what's your assessment of the
way the Republicans are going after
issues like gay marriage or pot
legalization or or even immigration if
you see that as a social issue yeah it's
still my view by the way it wasn't the
comment wasn't directed just that
so-called conservatives directed that
their opponents on the other side to it
was a general appeal
based on my belief which is stronger now
several trillion dollars of debt later
than it was then that we have urgent
problems we got to get this country on a
pro-growth footing we've got year we
need years of consistent high growth if
we're gonna remain a country of upward
mobility and opportunity and we've got
to get we've got to begin the process of
flattening this debt burden were about
to dump on future generations and I
thought that it would be wise to try to
rally the nation and focus the nation on
these problems which we all share and I
chose the word truce advisedly to
distinguish it from surrender or or
retreat you know just stand down
agree to disagree let's try to see if we
can't work on those things that
genuinely threaten us all that was the
idea and I think it's absolutely true
today you know we've we've just come
through a little storm in in my home
state oh yeah where I think there was
some there were some misunderstanding
and some unfairness and all that but
still I think it illustrates the fact
that that that these kind of issues can
get in the way of truly serious business
and so I I I think that this is this
this idea has a lot more
the agreement than many people think it
does even in 2012 after I it is 2011
actually after I had retained my sense
this is not you know run for national
office a Wall Street Journal reporter
who had trailed me around a little bit
and I've gotten to know called and said
they had put a questions on that subject
on their poll and a Republican primary
voters agreed with the idea of the truce
by something like seven to one so there
are people who are very passionate about
those issues they have a right to be and
they're and they will be heard but I
think in growing numbers Americans are
more concerned about other things and
many more are inclined to live and let
live at attitude how terrified are you
of an 18 trillion dollar debt and the
entitlements coming and washing down
when there doesn't seem to be a lot of
discussion even on the Republican side
anymore about doing much about that what
what is your articulated dread when your
wake up in the night sweating and
thinking about the future of our
accounts you know it's gonna be a huge
drag on growth it already is just
wait'll interest rates return to
anything live like normal from these
artificial levels and there are
certainly situations in which it could
threaten the country's future more more
seriously than that and it's there
there's a moral aspect to it I don't
think that it's by the way I don't blame
the American people they've been misled
about how all these things work it's
just my money
you know they stuck it in a book vault
in a drawer for me I'm just taking it
out you know people been actively misled
about it and
I don't think too many of our fellow
Americans knowingly would plunder their
children would borrow tons of money and
spend it on themselves to unconcern up
for themselves today that's exactly what
we're doing so I think there's a moral
dimension and economic dimension
I even worry about the national security
implications of a country that will soon
be spending upwards of 2/3 of all its
money on transfer payments and interests
you were a director of the Office of
Management and Budget I always get one
of those words wrong yeah at the kind of
dawn of the bush your Bush looking in
hindsight was no great fiscal steward of
these United States even if you isolate
military post 9/11 spending what went
wrong with Bush conservatism and fiscal
conservatism oh you know those numbers I
think have been largely misrepresented
but I'm not defending every decision
that was made at that time they were I
would have strongly preferred less
spending than happened but you know what
first thing went wrong was a bubble
burst so everybody I was one of the
guilty parties although so was Alan
Greenspan so it was the Congressional
Budget Office it was everybody Federal
Reserve and everybody else around
misunderstood that the revenue that was
coming in temporarily in the late 90s
was a base thought from which you could
project some sort of growth it wasn't
and when the stock market bubble burst
those revenues a lot of them evaporated
so the apparent fiscal strength of the
country was somewhat illusory
and then there's a recession that
followed the bubble then comes the war
the decision right or wrong to build a
homeland security capability and all
these things piled up on top so I think
after you've factored all those things
yeah there was some spending sometimes
too too
accommodate a Congress that was
reluctant necessarily to you know fund
the war on terror spending I mean it's a
unified Republican Congress for a large
part of that part of that time and so
again I think the the it's really a
historical to suggest that somehow I
used to spent a spent a flushed Treasury
Bear that's just nothing well I think
it's more of that total federal spending
non-defense grew by 50% in eight years
which is not fiscally conservative by
any stretch of the imagination
yeah it's I sometimes said I never had a
disagreement with anybody during the two
and a half years I was there where I was
for more spending than they were and
when we got a chance in Indiana to to
deal with a fewer zeros but a very
serious fiscal problem we found a way to
do so yeah you were referencing
reinventing government in the 1990 some
kind of intellectual stuff and even a
recent a recent former editor a beloved
figure of Virginia posture I wrote a
book called the future and its enemies I
understand that that had some influence
on you talk about that a little bit no I
thought it was a wonderful insight that
and it's certainly informed or or
colored my thinking when I got the
office
the dichotomy she Illustrated between
stasis and dynamism and those who are
comfortable with change recognize that
it's largely inevitable and therefore
that would go ought to be to shape it
and and adapt to it effectively and as I
mentioned already Indiana historically
has been a change of earth state and our
whole argument
everything we said and everything we
tried to do every speech iSpeech that I
gave for 10 years basically how does
their central theme that won't work
anymore that if you tread water in this
world you will sink and if you stand
still you will be passed by and that I
wanted Indiana to be an active vanguard
state and I think I can document that
after eight years we were we were looked
to in a variety of ways whether it's
infrastructure or fiscal probity or
education reform or property tax
controls or you name it or government
that works now talk about your role
Perdue a little bit here in most of the
country including where I'm from
California the story about universities
is all about a higher education bottled
bubble it's about tuitions trending like
this you've actually cut tuitions do I
have this right frozen frozen tuitions
how we have you been able to do that
edik I mean I don't consider we've done
anything particularly dramatic yet I
suggested to our board that we do this
and I'd only been there two or three
months when the decision had to be made
and so I didn't have nearly the
information to be sure but I had a
suspicion that we could do it and you
know limits have a lot of value
that's why balanced budget requirements
lead people to you know make decisions
they wouldn't otherwise make establish
priorities that they wouldn't otherwise
establish in business when times are
flush people are a little not as
attentive to that expense account or the
you know the less essential items sales
go flat suddenly people sharpen their
pencils so I thought if we establish
that limit and and I said to the campus
look we all care about this don't we we
all would like this the remains
the students from any income level they
can meet our standards can afford to
attend and people Purdue do agree with
that faculty staff everybody so I said
so let's all find ways to to do this
let's just I I said let's try something
different
instead of asking our students families
to adjust their budgets that are
preferred spending let's adjust our
spending to their budgets we did it once
and then we were able as it turned out
to extend it this second year will be at
least one more year to an extent it's a
statement that we believe that that
higher education ought to be of the
highest possible value and that
controlling costs maintaining access the
extent we can important part of that so
how have you done it what's the what's
the blueprint for Purdue well people
always want to know what some great
masterstroke there weren't too many of
those oh we had a very very expensive
health care benefit plan we modernized
it it's more consumerist and it's over
performing in terms of as it has all
over the country you know the minute
people get a little bit of skin back in
the game they start to ask common-sense
questions and weigh that experience in
indiana state government in a big way
so that was one we consolidated
information technology there - Wow big
big savings I think you being involved
with two successful large-scale IT
projects put you on a very short list of
people most uh most such things I won't
claim to have contributed anything
except the accept the determination that
it had to happen for those of us who
don't spend a lot of time on college
campuses and get our information through
oftentimes partisan media it can seem
like it's just a hell broth of micro
triggering and people in free speech
cages over in a corner what's your
assessment that the climate of free
speech on campus nationwide and that
Purdue is it as bad as some of us
suspects in places it obviously is we
all read about them and
you just shake your head I can I can
tell you that Purdue's different and I
think their you don't hear about the
places where free speech is respected
and protected naturally enough you don't
we feel very strongly about it about to
take some further actions to ensure that
what's been a good record remains that
way and we've we've identified some
small policies that were less than ideal
and we're we're changing those but no I
think that the spirit of free inquiry is
still strong on our campus and I hope on
most but clearly there are places where
the it's violated in truly unfortunate
ways well thank you very much for thank
you thank you very much and thanks for
the the good work and and the you know
provocative work that reasons always
done always been a courageous place and
one that held faithful to principle
that's why I've been a reader and often
agreed not always but I was always
stimulated you mean you're not ready to
legalize heroin I don't understand stop
short of that yeah well thank you it
should be a fun evening tonight
you